happy Halloween it's that time of year
when your neighbors are secretly
unwrapping candy and brushing lollipops
with poison and inserting razor blades
into pretty much everything actually
while it may be a holiday tradition to
view your neighbors as psychopaths who
patiently wait for the one trite day of
the year to kill the local kids in fact
no child has ever been killed by a
stranger's poisoned candy ever but you
know what facts don't stop fear here are
three ways in which our misguided terror
about Halloween is killing all the fun
[Applause]
parents are so scared of letting their
kids roam free that no joke there's now
a thing called trunk-or-treat
cars gather in a circle and kids go from
one trunk to the next to grab the candy
as if walking around in a circle in a
parking lot and collecting sugar is the
whole point of the holiday yeah sugar is
important but so is going outside with
your friends on your own at night
sometimes are so scared of the holiday
that they've placed curfews on
trick-or-treating it's medieval
it's as if they really believe that
ghouls come out at night there are
schools churches community centers
sending home notes begging parents not
to let their kids wear costumes that are
too scary as if kids can't handle an
eyeball losing blood anymore
one town even made a guy take down his
zombie decorations in his front yard
because they were quote too realistic in
other words they look too much like real
zombies
[Applause]
in some towns registered sex offenders
have to all gather together at the local
precinct like some twisted versions
study hall the rules are different in
different places but they're all based
on the idea that sex offenders pounce on
trick-or-treaters which turns out to be
like the poison candy story completely
false there was a study done by a
professor now at Johns Hopkins and she
found that there is ZERO increase in
child sex offenses on Halloween
in fact the author Elizabeth Letourneau
considered titling her study Halloween
the safest day of the year because it is
when it comes to sex crimes there's
really just one thing to fear on
Halloween and that's cars more kids get
hit by cars on Halloween than any other
day for obvious reasons there are so
many more kids outside so if we really
wanted to make the holidays safer we
would take up the cops who were checking
on the sex offenders and put them on
traffic patrol instead that could save
some lives
because cars are actually dangerous
unlike a slight bit torn Snickers bar
for reason TV I'm Lenore Eskenazi
you